la chronique de l'Echo clair combi
bonsoir
c'est le cœur de cette chronique de
l'écho
et vous êtes concerné puisque vous avez
vous avez été entrepreneur vous-même
donc justement le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur a fait beaucoup
parler de lui c'est ces dernières
semaines avec en questionnement une
réforme de ce régime alors tout d'abord
de quoi parle-t-on
l'auto-entrepreneuriat a été créé en
2009 à l'époque on voulait faciliter la
création d'entreprise et alléger les
démarches pour les petites activités
indépendantes c'était un test statut
cumulable on peut être auto-entrepreneur
et salarié ou demandeur d'emploi ou
étudiants pourquoi y a-t-il polémique et
bien ces auto-entrepreneurs sont
considérés par certains comme des comme
exerçant une concurrence déloyale disons
du fait de l'allègement des différentes
charges la ministre de l'Artisanat
sylvia Pinel a donc souhaité encadrer ce
statut malgré la gronde des
auto-entrepreneurs elle a confirmé hier
au Conseil des ministres le maintien de
son projet de réforme avec tout de même
des adaptations donc une imitation à
deux ans de ce statut
si le chiffre d'affaire donc dépasse
19000 euros pour les professions de
service ou 47 500 pour celles du
commerce on verra cela plus en détail
donc le débat n'est pas encore clos
puisque la loi devra passer normalement
par Le Mans en octobre sur ce plateau
nous recevons des Antilles et des
progresses on peut dire nous avons donc
Daniel Varlet bonsoir président de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat des
Yvelines vous êtes disons favorable à
une réforme de ce statut et Dominique et
marolo bonsoir délégué général de la
Fédération des auto-entrepreneurs et
vous nous direz vous pourquoi vous êtes
plutôt opposés nous avons également
Valérie rocher au riz qui éditrice et
qui nous fait le plaisir de rester sur
ce plateau pour un petit retour
d'expérience alors Daniel Varlet selon
les données vote de votre chambre vous
m'indiquez comptez 1700
auto-entrepreneurs dans le département
soit 10% des artisans alors en quoi
pose-t-il le problème entre guillemets
et bien c'est le problème n'est pas pas
forcément sur le département mais c'est
aussi dans l'ensemble du pays c'est ces
auto-entrepreneurs qui ont quand même la
chance de pouvoir
se projeter et avoir un projet et par
l'intermédiaire de ce statut pouvoir
commencer à
faire leur activité
sont des gens alors le statut c'est très
bien mais il faudrait que ça soit avec
pérenne dans le temps parce que c'est
vrai qu'à terme on trouve qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui nous concurrent
directement et qui n'ont forcément pas
le même régime un régime beaucoup plus
favorable pour ces gens par rapport à
nos artisans qui sont qui ont pignon sur
rue et qu'ils ont une activité
reconnue comme tel sur le département
alors les différents syndicats concernés
qui poussent vers une vraie forme
parfois assez loin ils cherchent à avoir
une harmonisation disons les différents
statuts d'entrepreneur est-ce que
finalement vous souhaitez
l'abolition de ce statut non pas du tout
puisque nous sommes
cet état de fait est quand même très
bien monsieur il y a des gens qui ont
des projets on a vu beaucoup de jeunes
qui voulaient un petit peu en
s'investissant en voulant pour voir un
petit peu l'activité réelle par rapport
à leur à leur leurs initiatives voir si
c'était adaptable à l'économie sur le
marché donc c'est un statut très bien
mais par contre faut qu'il soit limité
dans le temps Dominique Marleau de votre
côté vous estimez que cette concurrence
déloyale n'existe pas
monsieur a dit qu'il avait 10% de ses
artisans les autorentrepreneurs au
niveau national font 13% de la totalité
des auto-entrepreneur alors on peut
écouter mais ce qu'il faut embêter 87%
pour 13% qui ne font pas tous quand même
de la concurrence des loyers il y a pas
que les auto-entrepreneurs que vous ne
concurrence des voyages comme bagues je
voudrais donner un chiffre que vous
m'aviez demandé sur votre département il
y avait aux dernières statistiques que
nous avons dû 19948 au 333 Nord actifs
et 1122 qui avait déclaré du chiffre
d'affaires
donc s'il y en a 1000
1500 1300 la chambre des métiers il y en
a 10 000 qui ne sont pas la Chambre des
Métiers donc j'ai aussi relativiser cela
parce que
faut bien entendu que j'écoute monsieur
et bien entendu qu'on doit et c'est pas
la limitation dans le temps
les artisans et les gens du bâtiment ont
demandé la suppression du statut
monsieur gentillesse et l'honnêteté de
dire je ne demande pas bon ensuite ils
ont demandé l'harmonisation fiscale et
sociale pour que les petits artisans
bénéficient nous on est d'accord
là-dessus on est d'accord pour plein de
choses bien entendu mais aujourd'hui
qu'on essaye d'harmoniser qu'on essaie
d'améliorer la partie qui peut poser
problème mais qu'on n'embête pas 90%.
qui peuvent avoir des difficultés avec
des autres entrepreneurs moi je connais
beaucoup et Monsieur on connaissent
aussi certains des artisans qui
sous-traitent certains marchés des
auto-entrepreneurs parce que dans les
petits marchés qui ne peuvent pas
prendre ponctuellement etc donc il y a
c'est pas l'herbe toujours plus verte
dans le pré du voisin mais ce n'est pas
si blanc que cela et puis encore une
fois il y a 87% que Madame Pinel va
brider
puis je voudrais dire un autre point
puis après je laisserai monsieur bien
entendu ne pas être d'accord avec moi on
a parlé de concurrent des bruits avant
le temps que ça
et 90% des auto-entrepreneurs chez vous
ils ont fait 1000069 euros de chiffre
d'affaires en moyenne sur l'année
maintenant qu'ils vont être à 19 000 il
y a plus de concurrent nettoyage tout
d'un coup on est content parce que
Madame Pinel est limité à 19000 mais
alors dans 6 mois les artisans les
bâtiments nous ressortiront la
concurrence des loyales réglant une fois
pour toute
ce problème cette
incompréhension mettons-nous autour de
la table je disais monsieur tout à
l'heure nous la Fédération nous avons
demandé à Madame Pinel de nous mettre
autour de la table ensemble elle ne l'a
jamais fait vous avez été reçue
un petit peu l'approche qui est faite
même si nous disons elle est
certainement vrai sur un certain nombre
de cas mais faut la ramener à la
proportion qui qui la sienne
Valérie vous avez été vous-même
auto-entrepreneur vous allez changer de
statut pourquoi finalement le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur ne convient pas à
toutes les activités en tant qu'éditeur
j'ai des frais importants d'un primeur
de salon de déplacement etc donc je ne
pouvais pas les déduire donc c'était
faussé alors c'est un statut que
j'apprécié parce que il permet
effectivement de tester une action en
toute sécurité
j'apprécie aussi que le seuil au-delà
duquel on doit basculer en entreprise à
l'époque était assez élevé donc ça me
donnait quand même une certaine sécurité
mais c'est automatiquement que j'ai
basculé en entreprise parce que
fiscalement ça ne me convenait pas donc
j'ai bien entendu ce qui a été dit de ne
pas et d'autre mais je suis persuadée
que dans le cas d'un artisan de quand il
commence vraiment à se développer de
lui-même il va changer de statut parce
que l'autre entrepreneuriat n'est pas
très protecteur non plus au niveau
social donc bon voilà c'est mon
expérience mais je ne suis pas dans le
temps que quel est votre avis je pense
qu'elle se fait tout naturellement elle
se fait tout naturellement mais en
France on étouffe déjà avec un carcan de
réglementation de législation pour une
fois qu'on avait un espace de liberté il
faudrait peut-être pas le sucre est trop
chi alors avant de poursuivre on a posé
cette question à ce qu'il est ce qu'il y
a besoin d'une réforme ou non sur
l'auto-entrepreneuriat à des habitants
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je vous
propose d'écouter leurs réponses
oui effectivement c'est un système qui
n'est pas très favorable
c'est facile à mettre en oeuvre mais bon
avec ça on n'a pas de retraites
faire ce qu'il a envie il y a beaucoup
de gens courageux qui essayent vraiment
de monter leur petites entreprises c'est
pas facile je crois que vraiment on
laisse aucune chance pour les gens qui
veulent essayer de s'en sortir et par
rapport aux artisans je pense que oui
parce que je trouve qu'il y a trop de ou
autre entrepreneurs il y en a qui sont
très corrects mais il y en a d'autres
qui profitent de la situation pour
travailler au noir je pense que c'est un
excellent statut
ça permet à des quantités de gens de
d'avoir du travail qui ne pourrait pas
en avoir autrement
c'était une très bonne chose ça a permis
de créer des emplois